hi everyone it's time for another q a
video i'm gonna answer some of your
questions so i've asked my patrons
my wonderful wonderful patrons to ask me
some questions and i will do my best
to answer them right now so let's just
get started
okay so muhammad asks in your opinion
what was the main cause behind the fail
of rationalist and mystical schools of
thought in islam
in favor of more hardline and legalistic
schools of thought
i love that this is the kind of
questions i get
i was expecting what's your favorite
color and and this is
this is what i get i love it so this is
obviously a very
complex question uh
i'm not entirely sure what you're
referring to here
one thing could be that you're referring
to the early development of
theology and legal or jurisprudence in
the early
muslim community or civilization
um in that case i think first of all
that it's
we should be careful not to create this
kind of dichotomy between
rationalism and irrationalism and that
the irrationalists somehow won that's
not a very helpful way
to look at it but if you're referring to
the
debate between the people like the mua
tesla
or the the more
opinion the personal opinion oriented
jurists versus the more legalist
interpretations or people often as the
traditionalist or the added hadith
in that case i think there are many
different factors that contributed to
the
eventual uh victory or
the fact that the traditionalists gained
the upper hand i think
one reason is that their approach to
things was more appealing
to the general masses to the regular
person who wasn't
educated in theology or law they
presented a
first of all a theology that was more
graspable a god that was more
anthropomorphic that was more personal
that was that people could could imagine
and
devote their their prayers to in a more
direct way
in terms of law there was a lot more
defined
boundaries and and rules whereas the
other camp was sometimes a little more
fuzzy in that regard you know
having taking personal opinion into
into into regard and thus
resulting in many different practices in
different regions
whereas the more strict the
literalist interpretation allowed for a
more
unified practice throughout the empire
that was also of course very appealing
and very useful
in that sense i think another factor is
that in terms of theology you
as we talked about in one video the mua
tesla was
adopted by certain leaders like alma
moon
and actually forcibly implemented he
forced certain scholars to accept
watashi positions like the creativeness
of the quran
and and similar practices which which
led to the
general opinion that movements like the
tesla and related
ideas became associated with tyrannical
and oppressive rulers
whereas its counterpart was associated
with these
pious scholars who stood up for their
beliefs
but on the other hand we should also
remember that even though
the traditionalist camp the allen hadith
was of course very influential and
eclipsed the
my tesla and and the what you referred
to as rationalist
movements the people who actually
was victorious in the end were the
ashari's and the
maturities at least in terms of theology
and they
tried to create a kind of synthesis a
compromise in between the two extreme
positions
and also applied a reason and rational
thought
to their theology while also taking into
account
the more literalist
approaches at the same time so to say
that reason
or the rationalist approach fell in some
way
is as i said in the beginning somewhat
of a unhelpful
way to look at it you also talk about
the fall of the mystical schools of
thought
which leads me to believe that maybe
you're actually referring to
much later developments in the maybe
19th century
because sufism or tasawolf actually only
became more and more popular during the
first couple of centuries of
of the islamic civilization to the point
that in the
middle ages and forward it would come
like almost a majority expression of
islam and
remain so until around the 19th century
and when it did start to decline in
popularity at this point
that was actually in part because of
rationalist schools of thought because
in the 19th century we have these
movements and scholars
who we often refer to as islamic
modernist
associated with people like allah and
mohammed abdul
and his student rasheed and these
scholars were often very
critical of sufism they saw sufism as
this superstitious this old superstition
whereas
they were promoting a more rationalist a
more modernist
approach to islam they saw
the pure version original version of
islam as this rational
religion and some of these sufi
practices
like visiting the saints or graves of
saints
shrines and intercessionary prayers as
later
superstitious irrational innovations to
the religion and so what they were
trying to do was to reform
islam to remove these superstitious old
aspects
and to restore it to this pristine
rational form in which sufism
really didn't have much of a place
and and so this is i think the main
reason or one of the main reasons why
sufism is
not as prominent today at all especially
compared to
the way how popular it was and how
widespread it was
before this time up until the mid 19th
century
this is because these kind of modernist
rationalist approaches to the religion
became very popular across the islamic
world
it did lead to everything from salafis
to the islamic states
these are also based on this kind of
reform rationalist modernist approach to
to the religion anti-tradition but it
also led to things like
islamic feminism progressivism
so it's a very wide span but nonetheless
this general approach this rational
modernist approach
is definitely at least one of the main
factors
in my mind behind the the the decline in
popularity and and
practice of mysticism and well
sufism in the islamic world today
so in the end any kind of dichotomy like
this between rational or
legalist or or rational and sufi for
that matter of course i now presented a
view where rationalist and sufi was
opposed to each other which is not
necessarily the case
uh either but but nonetheless we can see
that
mysticism and rationalism does not
always go together
but also that we should always avoid
these kind of strong
divisions and dichotomies when talking
about
the history of of of anything really
it's it's rarely very helpful okay
question by despacitos if you could time
travel
or live witness a life in a certain
place where would that be and in which
era
this is such a difficult question
because obviously i would like to travel
to
every single destination and every
single time period because
every time period is interesting there's
always something that you
would like to know more about or
something you would like to experience
so this is almost impossible for me to
answer
because of course i am a scholar
of religion uh and i focused on things
like islam in the middle east
and of course like to go back to
palestine in the first century
and see what jesus was up to maybe ask
him like
who are you what are you doing
or for that matter also maybe go to
medina or mecca in the 7th century and
experience what it was like in the
community of the prophet muhammad for
example
these things would be of course
incredibly interesting but there's also
something to be said for the fact that
things maybe sometimes should be
left a mystery there's
a kind of romantic notion that we have
about certain historical
events or places and i think in a lot of
cases if we were to actually experience
them
it wouldn't really be like we expected
it to be and we would be
somewhat disappointed reality is rarely
as
interesting as the way we imagine or
romanticize reality so
maybe some things are best left uh
mysteries and some questions are best
left unanswered but
you know i can't deny the fact that it
would be really interesting to see
what happened in for example in the
communities of jesus or
muhammad so that would be one of my
answers at least
question number three from eric
goodimoth excuse me if i'm pronouncing
that incorrectly
have you ever heard of a religion called
yarisanism
yes i have russianism is a very
interesting
religious movement from what is the day
iran in persia it is connected to sufism
of course
it's also known as the halihach the
people of truth i don't know all that
much about them there are
some of you have requested me to make a
video about them at some point and i
might actually do that but i would have
to do some more research because it's a
it's a field that i'm not that familiar
with uh
i do have certain acquaintances and
friends especially some
musician friends who are
loosely connected to the ali movement so
i'm also familiar with them in that
sense they
they have of course very strong musical
traditions they love to play the tambur
which is a
an amazing instrument uh but more than
that
i i don't know that much i know that
there's a strong connection to
sufism but also certain local persian
traditions
and so i would i will definitely explore
that in the future in
in some video but for now my answer is
yes
i know about them but i don't know that
much
about them we also have a question from
a lulia forge
foresh again i'm sorry about these
pronunciations but the question is why
are you interested in sufism and the
lives
of sufi saints why especially north
africa
do you think that there have been a
decline in sufi practices in the last
100 years
in terms of the very last question yes i
did tackle some of that in in the first
question
certainly sufism has declined to some
degree in popularity in the islamic
world since the
19th century at least in comparison to
the
widespread flourishing of sufism that
was before that but at the same time i
think in the last few decades
or so sufism has also started to see a
kind of resurgence
some people have seen sufism as a kind
of antidote to more
extremist ideologies like the salafists
or wahhabis
of course if that's a legitimate
position this is a question for another
time but but certainly i think sufism
is starting to uh
gain followers or gain popularity again
both in the islamic world but also
outside
in the west and different kinds of sufi
movements so
so yes and no i guess as for the other
question why are you interested in
sufism and the lives of stupid saints
well who wouldn't be i mean you've seen
my videos
i think it's just such a fascinating
subject
the the sufis are some of the most
interesting and fascinating people
i think who have ever lived i just love
the way that
the sufis and well mystics in general
express
their kind of experiences their ideas
it's rarely in a kind of dry
philosophical
manner like some like what regular
philosophers would do like
arguments and and explanations and
instead the sufis and the mystics they
just kind of throw things
out there they experience things and
then they just
often in in poetry or inverse or in
music they express these
experiences in very fascinating and
inspiring ways and so i i
i guess that's one of the reasons it's
just such a
colorful and wonderful and
philosophically appealing
often uh thing that i just
completely fell in love with at some
point and why especially north africa i
don't i don't know i i don't know if i
am especially interested in north africa
i think
on this channel i have focused a lot on
on sufism
in andalusia and and the maghrib in
north africa
i've done videos
i think one of the reasons is that
persian sufism
gets all the fame you know people love
to talk about marumi
hafez and atar and of course
we should talk about them because
they're amazing but they
there's so much about them already you
can find so much information i think
the sufis of the western
regions in these maghrib and southern
spain
are often forgotten except for ibn arabi
and so
that's one of the reasons why i've been
interested in
focusing on them in particular to
highlight some of these people who who
tend to be forgotten
in these kinds of discussions but
nonetheless have a lot to offer and have
impacted sufism and and mysticism in
general to a very large degree
so that would be my main answer okay the
patron
nathan p asks what is your dream for the
channel and where would you like it to
go
well i think my dream for the channel
was for it to be basically where it is
right now
that it is a kind of hub or a forum
where
we can spread knowledge about
religion about all aspects related to
religion and to
create a more open
a more informed discussion about these
subjects both
in a kind of top-down matter as as for
the channel to
to be a source of information but also
for the channel to be
a source for discussion in things like
the comments and so on
um that's definitely one of the goals i
have with it i would like to extend the
scope of the channel to to maybe
collaborate
with other people have other scholars
perhaps do certain videos or host videos
or series
we'll see where that's going to go but i
have some of those plans to to expand
the channel to a certain degree okay
last question
also from nathan where do you think
religion could go in the future
the issues with modernization you may
see
this is a very very difficult question
um
a couple of decades ago the kind of
scholarly
consensus or scholarly trend was to say
that religion was on its way out
that in a century or two religion would
be
completely gone replaced by scientific
progress or rational thought
now of course a couple of decades later
now we know that that was
very inaccurate religion has actually
resurfaced it's only become
more popular lately so it's very
difficult to say
various reasons for this and religion
also i think
evolves as it always has we evolved over
time
in one video i talked about this
phenomenon which is often called
believing without belonging even though
religious institutions like christianity
for example the church
does not have the same power as it used
to
and people don't identify with these
larger
institutions in the same way that they
used to nonetheless people continue
to a very large degree to believe in
things and to practice different kinds
of
well religious or spiritual practices
people
believe in gods or spirits they believe
in an afterlife
so even if religions
as in the big religions will decrease
or lose more power which it it's not
seeing like it will
in any time soon but even if so i think
religion will
live on in some other way there's
can have different theories about it but
there seems to be something inherently
human
in our human nature that just wants to
express
itself in a certain way and so i think
religion
in its various forms is not going
anywhere anytime
soon but in what form it will remain it
is very hard to to say
so that i guess we'll see so that was
all the questions for now i hope that
was at least
somewhat understandable and satisfying
and then i wasn't just
rambling the entire way through um
i'll do one of these sometime soon maybe
once every two months or so and
if you want to get the opportunity to
ask questions for these q a videos then
you should become a patron i will leave
a link to my patreon page in the
description
and so you can check out the different
tiers you can make a decision and you
will get
wonderful exclusive rights
exclusive
exclusive benefits like this one you get
to ask me
questions that i can vaguely answer in
these q a videos
until then i'll be releasing videos
hopefully on a weekly basis uh at least
in the foreseeable future i'm working on
a couple of things right now
which i will not disclose yet but look
forward to that soon
and yeah i'll see you next time
you